Iran is reinstating checks by the
so-called morality police months after
the death of a woman in their custody
provoked by Nationwide protests provoked
Nationwide protests rather Street
patrols are restarting to ensure women
cover their heads in public the patrols
were suspended following the death of
Masa amini last September at least 500
people were killed in nearly 20 000
arrested during weeks of protests Cinema
kasuaglu has more from Tehran
I can't say that this has been well
received as many women to cut their head
scarves especially following Masa I mean
his death 10 months ago and since then
we haven't seen morality police
patrolling around that often and some of
them even
considered that the morality police was
disbanded but of course on April 15 the
Islamic Republic officials reminded that
they had scarf is still was still
obligatory and women need to wear a
hijab but after this morning's statement
by the police spokesperson we understand
that many Iranian women are concerned
they're concerned that the morality
police is going to pressure them as we
have seen many more women taking out
hijab especially in the middle class and
upper class districts of Tehran we see
many young women without hijab and they
are wearing more casual and they are
more visible than ever and we are here
that in some other cities there are
again young women who are who already
took up their hijab after masamine is
that and the protest but of course this
is not the majority of the Iranian women
for now but they are concerned about
this they're concerned how this will uh
unyield but of course it is it has just
been one day we haven't seen any
morality police patrolling around so far
things are of course prone to fragility
in Iran and we will see what is going to
happen but I must say that women are not
happy about this